thank you to skillshare for supporting
this episode of journey to the micro
cosmos
and if you are one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description
you can get a two-month free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
[Music]
there are no ghosts in the micro cosmos
there is no halloween in the micro
cosmos but if there were this flatworm
would fit in quite nicely with its
spectral appearance it might be
navigating its way through a field of
other organisms but it looks like it had
three minutes to prepare for a costume
party and decided to go with the classic
old bed sheet with eyeholes ghost
costume
and maybe comparing this flatworm or
even worms in general to a ghost
is kind of apt ghosts straddle
two worlds and so do worms
though in their case instead of bridging
the realm of the living and dead
worms manage to stretch between the
micro
and the macro this creature you're
watching now would probably
be difficult to see without a microscope
but
on the other end there are worms that
are meters
too long to observe with a microscope
and akin to ghosts worms might seem like
a sort of
reduced form of life after all
for a lot of us worms are the weekly
tubes that we dug up from playgrounds
and of all of the worms flatworms are
perhaps
the most simple of all but even
digging into what it means to be the
simplest worm
makes the whole notion of simplicity
seem
ludicrous so let's start with the
broader question
what are worms other than wiggly
self-mating tubes while we generally
use the word worm to describe many
different
unrelated invertebrate tubular animals
that belong
to a number of different phyla there are
three main phylum that people focus on
the first are our flatworm buddies here
who are known more
formally as the platyhelminthes then
there is the phylum nematoda
known less formally as roundworms we've
come across
nematodes many times in our journey
through the microcosmos which makes
sense
given that they are one of the most
abundant animals on this planet
and last are the analyta phylum
of our playground friend the earthworm
well earthworms are a bit beyond the
scope
of the micro if you will we've also got
this
little stylaria lacustress at the tip of
its head
is the proboscis an antenna-like
structure
that the worm uses for feeding and as we
scan
past the head you can see that the
length of the stylarious body
is segmented of the three phyla we've
mentioned
annelids are the most complex they have
a closed
circulatory system with tubes that
transport
nutrients and oxygen throughout their
body
as well as a complete digestive system
that has
both a mouth to take in food and an anus
to get rid of waste
if we think of worms in general as a gut
enclosed within a body wall then that
gut
is a tube and the body is a tube and you
can imagine
that worms are a tube inside a
tube and what separates these different
groups is the space that separates
one of those tubes from the other
complex systems
inside annelids are due to what's called
a celium
a tissue-lined cavity that sits between
the tube of the digestive tract
and the tube of the body wall
importantly this cavity
is filled with fluid which facilitates
the development of
organs along with the transport of
nutrients
around the body the development of the
first
celium was a very big deal because
celiums don't just allow
anilids to have complex systems they
connect the seemingly simple
organisms we're talking about here to
more complex animals
like us because anilids and humans
are both what is known as celamates or
euselamates we are animals that have
celeums so thank you to the ancestor
that we
share with earthworms who developed the
first celem
who allowed more complex organisms like
you
to exist nematodes on the other hand
are what are called pseudocelimates
they still have a cellem-like
fluid-filled cavity but the cavity
isn't lined with tissue like you find in
true selenes
other microscopic pseudocylomates
include gastrotricks
and rotifers this pseudocellulum
is a slight but significant difference
in nematodes when compared to annelids
corresponding to a slightly less complex
body plan
though nematodes still do have a
complete digestive system
the flatworms are the simplest of all
starting with the coelom flatworms don't
actually have one they are considered
acelamates that area between the gut
and body wall where anilids and
nematodes have a cavity full of fluid
is instead full of tissue this has a few
consequences for the flatworm but
one of the biggest ones is that the area
can't support the development of
specialized
systems that you see in other animals
the lack of celium
imposes limits on the flatworm's body
and
lifestyle reducing both its complexity
and size but that does not mean the
flatworm lives
a simple life
[Music]
of the three worm groups flatworms
are the most like a tube within another
tube
except that their outer tube is much
less cylindrical
the flat in flatworm is actually an
adaptation without a circulatory system
or
respiratory system the worm relies on
diffusion
across its outer membrane to supply
cells
with oxygen being flatter
gets the cells closer to the outside and
better positioned
for diffusion and without the ability to
build a complete digestive system like
those found in nematodes and annelids
flatworms have to adjust to life without
that
most underappreciated body part of all
the anus they take in food through one
opening
digest it in their gut and then spew the
waste back out
from that same opening so unlike other
organisms who have separate entrances
and exits for their food
the flatworm must wait to finish
digesting
before it can eat again but this is not
the only way flatworms can get rid of
waste their body is lined with a special
type of
cell called a flame cell that also gets
waste out of the worm while it may not
have the elegance of an
interconnected set of organs this system
is
its own form of complexity basically
every flame cell is one
single celled kidney allowing the worm
to just
ooze waste from its skin and this is
just scratching the surface
of the biological intricacy flatworms
are capable of
like many of their more involved worm
counterparts flatworms can reproduce
both
asexually and sexually and when
reproducing sexually
they can mate with another flatworm or
even with themselves both making
and fertilizing their own eggs there's
also
those flatworm species that can
regenerate a trick
that our more developed bodies are alas
not
capable of even the many weird ways they
move
make the word wiggle feel reductive
[Music]
our perception of simplicity across
nature is built on comparisons compared
to us on earthworm may seem simple
put that earthworm next to a flatworm
and suddenly the earthworm
represents a gigantic biological
advancement
but then put that flatworm next to a
bacteria
and suddenly it contains multitudes
it is a universe that flatworm is a
marvel an almost unbelievable testament
to the power of evolution
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore
the unseen world that surrounds us
like a lot of people you might be
working from home right now
and there can be a lot of unique
struggles
that come along with that thanks to
skillshare classes like
work from home as a creative you could
learn new strategies to make your work
from home days even more efficient
host ameris henderson is a commercial
illustrator who will teach you
some creative strategies for staying on
top of your task and
overall just being the most productive
at-home creator you can be
and skillshare is an online learning
community that offers
membership with meaning with so much to
explore
real projects to create and the support
of fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth
and it makes it easy with short classes
that'll fit into your daily routine
a premium membership will give you
unlimited access
so you can join the classes and
communities that are right for you
and an annual subscription to skillshare
is less than ten dollars a month
and if you're one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description
you can get a two-month free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
and thank you of course to all the
people whose names are on the screen
right now
these are the people who make this
channel possible so if you like it
you have them to thank thank you so much
to all our patrons if you are interested
in becoming one of them you can go and
check it out
at patreon.com journey to micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss check out
jam and germs on instagram and if you
want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby